welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and I have been waiting for the
Super Mario Bros movie trailer to drop
Super Mario Brothers bro I'm saying Bros
it tells us so much about what the plot
could potentially be and there were a
surprising number of details that you
might have missed so let's jump into it
as certain plumbers are wanting to do
so we open on an isolated little ice
kingdom seemingly in the middle of
nowhere we'll come back to that when
suddenly a massive Bowser Airship
menacingly approaches spewing lava onto
the ice as it goes the classic fire ice
contrast reminiscent of the freezer
flame Galaxy from Super Mario Galaxy and
the war drums playing in the background
tell us that something is about to go
down and we already know who has the
upper hand when fire meets eyes when the
ship gets closer to the kingdom we get a
better idea of exactly how huge this
ship is this Airship is bigger than the
entire city that's a pretty nice upgrade
from the clown car although like 95 of
it is covered in lava so not very space
efficient decorating this Airship is
similar to Bowser's ship and Paper Mario
and even uses the same giant chain maces
to dock crushing pillars and
demonstrating the huge imbalance of
power in the process on to the next part
of the trailer
[Music]
thank you
we then cut to Comic famously Bowser's
advisor and right-hand man grandly
announcing the arrival of the king of
Koopas he's flanked by a troop of Koopas
who yields Spears and flags which as we
know from the games are the goal polls
at the end of unbeaten levels I wonder
if they went with that design choice
because the Army itself is unbeaten you
get a glimpse of some paratroopas in the
front and some red green blue and
potentially some other colored Koopas
throughout the Army now there aren't too
many differences between the colors of
Koopas like in the games the main
difference between the red and the green
Koopas are just their walking paths when
they come to a cliff red Koopas will
turn around and walk the other way
whereas green Koopas will just walk off
the ledge
[Music]
[Applause]
this ranking difference could be
reflected in the movie in which case I'm
gonna guess maybe the red ones might be
a little higher ranking and that theory
is demonstrated when we're shown a
confident seemingly bloodthirsty red
Koopa and a fearful shaking green Koopa
standing next to each other speaking of
that red Koopa has an aesthetic eye
patch yeah I said aesthetic spiky
shoulder pads and maybe acne scarring
that seems to indicate he might be a
more prominent character in this flick
you can't give a Koopa acne scars and
not have him at least have a liner too
it's also worth noting that the Koopa
troopas in the game always seem to have
a loyal yet kind of doofy unprofessional
Vibe and judging from the fact that when
Comics announcing Bowser one of the
Koopa troopas is extremely fidgety can't
stand still and the one next to him
looks bored AF I'm hopeful they keep
that same comedic relief in the movie so
out from the ship comes King Bowser
himself now Bowser's design has stayed
pretty dang consistent throughout the
years and it looks like the movie
version doesn't stray from that okay
back to the trailer open the gates
you
the time he demands the ice Kingdom's
Gates be open and when they do the Mist
clears and we see penglings and king
penguin penguin King is the IMDB credits
call him I was curious to see if this
was a kingdom we had seen before in the
games to maybe explain why Bowser was
fighting them in particular looking at
the Kingdom itself it mainly consists of
these Dome top towers that appear to be
made out of compact ice due to the way
they crumble when hit they all seem to
have a blinding blue glowing light
emitting from them and not much else
which doesn't seem like a super nice
place to live when you ask someone which
room they want they're like oh God I
guess I'll take this bright ass one over
here now that Dome shape has been seen
in the background of a few ice levels in
past games but the Aurora Borealis that
surrounds them points me towards the
Frosted Glacier World in new Super Mario
Bros U Deluxe that background also
captures that same desolate Wasteland
that this Kingdom seems to be in and
they got pagans this particular Kingdom
isn't seen in any of the games though
and penguin King is definitely a new
character brought to life by Kari Payton
who you might recognize as the voice of
Cyborg from Teen Titans Go since these
penguins have a king they clearly aren't
under the direct rule of Princess Peach
but there's something that might suggest
that there's some relation there in the
trailer we see two different types of
flags on top of the towers and no matter
how much I zoom in and mess with the
colors I cannot for the life of me tell
what the symbols are supposed to be
maybe a mushroom gets so fuzzy but
what's interesting is the two flags we
see match the colors of the flags of
Princess Peach's castle in some of the
games now in some of the games they're
solid red and then others they're white
with a pinkish red outline both are
swallowtail Flags meaning it Forks into
two points which you hardly ever see in
Mario games so although these little
chili dudes probably have their own
thing going on they could potentially
have some sort of Allegiance or
relationship with the Mushroom Kingdom
now as adorable as these little guys are
they're black leather harnesses Battle
Scars and immediate call to attack
suggests the penguins are no strangers
to violence also me when no one wants to
support the mozzarella sticks with me
let's move on yeah
do you yield I do not
finally found it now who's gonna stop me
unfortunately these Savage cuties
hurling snowballs does absolutely
nothing to hurt Bowser aside from a
trebuchet snowball absolutely
obliterating a red Koopa it hits a
sentence I never thought I'd say
undeterred penguin King asks if Bowser
yields Bowser's like nah and comic uses
his powers to toss him aside before
Bowser unleashes a devastating fire
blast that destroys at the very least
the front of the palace walls in the
frontmost tower in the next shot we see
Bowser standing over a glowing Power
Star exclaiming I finally found it now
who's gonna stop me I know I should have
voiced Bowser thank you you now there
are three types of power Stars this
could be the grand star which Bowser
uses in Super Mario Galaxy to turn into
the much more powerful Giant Bowser the
type of star that just makes the user
temporarily invincible and the types of
stars you acquire when beating levels or
worlds that you have to collect to beat
the game since it doesn't look like the
grand star and it has more weight to it
than a temporary invincibility star I
think it's the third option and when
Bowser says I finally found it he means
he found the last star in the collection
of stars that he needs to gain more
Powers this one makes sense because it
explains why this little penguin Kingdom
would have such a valuable item in their
possession and would imply that Bowser's
been going from Kingdom to Kingdom
destroying lands and taking their Stars
very Thanos of him which might also
explain the severity of his fire blast
that he used on this Kingdom Bowser's
always had a powerful fire blast but the
scope of this one might imply that he's
already stronger with the other power
stars in his possession like me with
boots the more boots I own the stronger
I am let's keep going foreign
lovable hero who's blasted screaming out
of a pipe into a land full of mushrooms
where he ungracefully eats it by the way
the archway the pipe stems from is made
of red brick which I think is a cute nod
at the importance of red bricks in the
Mario games red bricks not being as
cartoony as we're used to on this
building might even demonstrate a
merging of the world Mario's coming from
and the one he's entering more on that
in a bit but archways also commonly
represent a Gateway a sort of Passage or
transition into new opportunity so here
we have an every man who's forcefully
thrust past a threshold via pipe into a
new and foreign land where he must
Embrace new situations in order to grow
and become the hero he's destined to be
first he eats it his offer in
Timberlands are looking great though
let's move on
foreign
what is this place
oh I'm sorry that one's perfectly fine
then a slowed down mystical version of
the music that was in the first level of
the 1985 NES Super Mario Bros plays as
Mario looks around at his surroundings
in awe that's right we're getting
Mario's introduction to the Mushroom
Kingdom in this one which is wild my
reasoning for them setting it in this
place in the timeline is that it allows
the non-gaming viewers to absorb
Exposition with Mario acting as the
audience surrogate this movie is clearly
trying to appeal to the biggest audience
possible and having everything explained
out loud prevents Grandpa from asking
why that half-naked mushroom is
following that mustache it would man
around and yes I saw they gave toad
pants instead of a diaper but that
doesn't mean I have to like it hours so
one of the biggest questions I have with
this being Mario's first introduction to
the Mushroom Kingdom is where is he
coming from they could go in so many
directions with this could he be coming
from New Dong city after all the Mario
Odyssey universe is canon in this I'll
prove that in a second could he be
coming from New York where Mario was
believed to have hailed for a Time Chris
Pratt does do a little tinge of a New
York accent could they be creating
another cartoonish human world just for
this movie Donkey Kong and Cranky Kong
are in this movie according to IMDb
could he have been staying with them
they could really go in any direction
with it so we finally get to hear the
Chris Pratt voice we've all been waiting
on pins and needles for and to me he
kind of sounds like a like an energetic
Gigi from piki's delivery service no
just me Gigi look it's me so Mario
reaches for a blue mushroom and we get
to hear voice we've been dying to hear
number two Keegan Michael Kia's toad who
drops the shrillness that
characteristically comes with Toad's
voice but keeps the slight gargle on
exclamations I do think these are
probably good adjustments for a movie
where you're probably gonna hear toad
talk a lot there's a reason we only hear
that gradingly lovable voice and short
verse in the games but I will say if we
don't get at least one wow I'm going to
Riot so toad warns Mario not to touch
the blue mushroom or he'll die before
correcting himself this is almost
certainly a play on the fact that there
are poison mushrooms in the games that
are purple which is why he would mistake
a blue mushroom for one fun fact though
blue mushrooms in the games are mini
mushrooms so he did say Mario from
getting real tiny toad is also holding a
walking stick and wearing a backpack
full of gear that is perfectly suited
for an adventure it's got a lantern some
rope a blanket a mug a frying pan and
even some decorative pins zoom in on
those pins and you'll see that one is a
Princess Peach's castle and the other
two are the upside down pyramid and
toast Arena and the dinosaur from
Cascade Kingdom both from Mario Odyssey
till jab prove it was Canon now we've
seen a toad exploring with a backpack in
Mario games before named captain Toad
but the backpack did look a little
different and this toad doesn't Dawn the
same attire so we'll just have to wait
and see if this could potentially be the
future Captain Toad anyway back to the
trailer come on Mario out
Mushroom Kingdom Here We Come next we
see toad leading the way towards the
kingdom in the great expanse between
where they are in the castle there's a
lot going on we see several dome-like
rock formations which is referencing the
bizarre capsule-shaped Hills seen in the
background of some Mario games what are
those by the way why have we always just
accepted them so easily some of them
have them have eyes The Hills Have Eyes
you also see lots of little splotches of
color along the long and winding road
that give the vibe of the different
lands that Mario goes through on his
road to Victory throughout the games of
course front and center is Princess
Peach's castle which poses it as the
destination of their journey and as we
get a little closer to the castle the
density of the population seems to grow
as it becomes difficult to tell what are
mushrooms and what are mushroom houses
or buildings there does seem to be a
village of sorts underneath the castle
though which is almost certainly toad
town the capital city of the Mushroom
Kingdom now there's an interesting
difference between the trailer and the
poster for this movie and that is that
in the poster there are a lot more
floating islands and or planets in the
sky that seem to come straight out of
Super Mario Galaxy the trailer version
has a few sparse floating islands but
nothing demonstrating the anti-gravity
physics that the poster displays however
like the poster there is a series of
Blocky vertical Cliffs that lead up to
the castle which to me are very
reminiscent of the side-scrolling
portions of Super Mario Galaxy 2 where
you need to scale large vertical
Cliffside it'll be interesting to see
how the alternate planets that accompany
the Mario galaxy universe being Canon
will play into everything okay back to
the trailer
then we're hit with the title which uses
the same logo design that Super Mario
has used since 2011 when Super Mario 3D
Land was released an interesting note
though is that it has a white outline
like the Super Mario Galaxy logo does as
opposed to the black outline of the
usual logo and there's a gleaming
Sparkle on the tip of the r and the
Galaxy logo is also known for having
sparkles on the edges of some of its
letters I don't know if it means
anything but it's neat this title screen
also reminds us that the movie is called
the Super Mario Bros for a reason
because last but not least we have a
scene with Luigi in the end where he's
being chased through some dark and
spooky woods by a horde of dry bones he
frantically makes his way across a mode
of lava towards a castle which is
actually pretty busted up when you look
at it but out of the top stands an
unbeaten Bowser flag this Castle looks a
lot like the classic fortresses from
Super Mario World then he barricades
himself Inside by pushing against the
door some people have speculated that
this is a mansion as a reference to the
game Luigi's Mansion but the exterior
the giant wooden bar lock and the rubble
we see at his feet tells me this is
probably an abandoned castle or Fortress
but fortresses and castles in Super
Mario World still had plenty of booze
ghosts not liquor so I'm sure Luigi's
still bound to have a paranormal
encounter or two I can't wait to see
more of what this movie has in store and
I Know Jack Black's had in an interview
that we'd be surprised to see that
Bowser has a musical side so I'm rooting
for a musical number with a tap break in
his white coattails for the next trailer
and let us know in the comments if you
want to see more videos on Mario or
gaming or gaming or video games just let
us know in the meantime you can follow
me on Twitter at it'sanavanston and
follow And subscribe to new rockstars at
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love
[Music]
okay I just wanna wear anything I'm
melting